hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2019 world rabbit
championship
it's a Hikaru Nakamura versus Magnus
Carlsen and Magnus is a full point ahead
of everyone else the only the only two
people who can catch up to Magnus are
Hikaru Nakamura who is on ten points and
Vladislav artemyev who is also on ten
points now our taymiyah faces Du Bois
and here
well a lot of things can happen I don't
think they've calculated everything yet
but for example only two players can go
into into the playoffs even even though
for example if he karo beats Magnus here
both of them will be on eleven points
and if our team of beats do both then
artemiev also goes to 11 points and then
you have to see who has the better boo
holes and additional criteria and then
one of them is eliminated and two of
them go into playoff so which means that
if Nakamura beats Magnus and that time
it beats dubov maybe Magnus will be
eliminated and then Nakamura and their
teammate will go into playoffs or
Nakamura beats Magnus and then Nakamura
is eliminated and then Magnus in their
time you go into playoffs so a lot of
crazy and unfair possibilities are
possible you know to unfold but best we
just check out the game so Nakamura with
the white pieces opens with efore again
challenging Magnus to his Sicilian
defense Magnus replies with c5 with
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
b5 Nakamoto goes for the news Medina
Barroso limo attack and two of them
already played this variation in the
single Cup this year we even covered
this game so maybe you even remember it
- the game ended in a draw so it's it
will be interested interesting to see
what nakamura prepared for for the next
time he faces Magnus in this line g6 as
they played in the sinful cup Nakamura
castles at Bishop to g7
and rook to e1 with E 5 not allowing
white to push evite himself Bishop
captures D captures and now d3 so fairly
standard stuff this is what Magnus
always goes for we have Queen to c7 and
Bishop to e3
and going after the c5 pawn b6 defending
and now a3
yeah we have a 5 by Magnus and now that
Knight B to d2
Magnus continues development night if
six and the now before exactly what
Nakamura played against the Magnus in
the scene filled cup nights the g4 by
Magnus goes after the dark square bishop
we have B captures on c5 Knight captures
on e3 with F captures on e3 and now B
captures on c5 and here nice to see four
since Magnus has no B or D pawn the
night has an excellent outpost on c4 and
you have a lot of pressure on the e5
pawn so Bishop to e6 and the now Knight
f2 d2 if the knight is captured then
this night can take it take its place
finally Magnus castles and here in the
singled Cup Nakamura played rook the b1
but he sorry he played rook the f1 but
here he goes rook to be one and it is as
a move 15 that we have a completely new
game so what is the poison that Nakamura
prepared Magnus immediately counters the
rook rook F to be 8 and here Nakamura
trades rook captures with rook captures
and now Quinta a one with ideas of maybe
trading the other work would work to be
one but also the Queen can be activated
maybe with Queen to c3 we have a four by
Magnus not allowing the e4 pawn to
remain a target so now the Queen can
move with Queen to c3 also there are
ideas of maybe just offering the Queen
trade here but then you might have some
problems with with the infant in
infiltration of the rook if the knight
no longer covers b2 so we have looked
the b5 not allowing this da v square is
covered and now rook the f1 we have f6
by Magnus and here comes h3 and all of
these moves were played instantly both
of them are above 15 minutes on the
clock and you start the game with 15
minutes on the clock so here we have h5
by Magnus not allowing the further
expansion with g4 keeping those pawns at
bay and here we have Queen to a-1 by
Nakamura which makes the rook to be one
a possibility if you want to trade rooks
makes Queen well maybe Queen to d1 - if
three a possibility if you want to
activate the Queen this way but it was
in this position that Hikaru Nakamura
offered the draw
and it was also in this position that
magnus carlsen accepted a draw and the
position is full of possibilities of
course but magnus only needs a draw to
win the title of the world rapid
champion so he accepted of course and
nakamura very happy to take a draw
against Magnus in the final round even
though with the white pieces puts him on
10 and a half points and I've just seen
before I started recording the video
that Artemyev and the dubov also drew
their game so it's Magnus with 11 and a
half Nakamura and artemiev with 10 and a
half so it doesn't mean that nakamura
and their team you've got a second and
third place we still have to see because
mama DRF and ali reza ferocious still
have a possibility to catch up to
Nakamura and artemiev but they are
playing against each other
so if mama Diarra wins he can catch up
to Nakamura and their teammate if Rosie
wins he can also catch up to them and if
mama dia of and ferocious draw the game
which I don't think will happen as
Nero's and gets the podium then but but
it it also could so that's the story of
how Magnus Carlsen won the world rapid
championship in 2019 I do hope you enjoy
that do use hash tag suggestion tomorrow
I'm gonna go through all of your
suggestions and show the games that
we've missed as we've been covering
Magnus games since he pretty much
obliterated the field so I do suggest so
just the way and I'm gonna go through
them and cover some some other nice
games so yeah I once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Michael
Carey Pete spawn Robles a victor client
David Raskin and pray the reserved for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
blitz championship and also the games
some of the games from the rapid that we
missed
checking up in r1 for suggestions and so
on so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
Saturday I'm off to grab a beer